l vous savez quoi au juste pas
grandchose je suppose mais j'apprends
vite vous savez et je suis un dieu
commençons par les bases alors c'est
par toute
l'existence pour grave
danger le TVA a disparu truc s'app ATV
et non on en a reçu de la semaine
dernière j'ai besoin de votre aide pour
a à le réparer un
rassemblement si vous le faites trop
tard vous resterez bloqué dans le FL
temporel pour
toujours Mobius n'aura plus de peau
c'est
clair maintenant écoutez-moi enfon le
bouton vert il est peut-être
collant surtoutemble pas
alors c'est maintenant
jamais je dois te montrer quelque
chose je crois que vous êtes
au j'ai pris toute la ville de New York
en otage avec des coloss l'espace ça
arrive à tout le
monde